foreign
Texas and talk to Sydney Hey Sydney
what's up
hey Dr Delaney can I give you a shout
out first real quick you can do all
things what's up okay well first of all
I'm listening to your own your past
change your future so I'm trying to do
that and it's helping so much also your
anxiety book is helping me I'm on
um the myth of anxiety can be cured only
with medication but
um this is really special I purchased
your
questions for humans cards for our
eight-year-old grandson who lives with
us so sometimes he drives us nuts we
don't know what else to do with him and
he's eight Sydney that's what they do
they're just right oh man but I'm a
grandparent you know so he just
these cards have been life-changing and
we ordered the second set as well
but he's now starting to make up his own
questions you know he did all your first
questions now he's starting the
questions and so you know I've sent them
to other people and what a great idea
well you have been so helpful
and my other shout out is to Dave Ramsey
my husband and I have worked our tails
off we've eaten beans in our eyes and
we're completely debt free way to go
counting everything oh wow you don't owe
anybody anything right nope not at all
and we live in Texas in a big old house
and and it's yours it's all yours no one
can take it no one can take my cars I've
had that happen before
oh you know what an anxious life is huh
well um thank you for picking up the
books and and working through them uh
I'm I'm currently right in the middle of
writing another one um and it's an
expansion on the redefining anxiety one
it's a much bigger how to build an
unanxious life which I'm excited about
um and it really combines those two
books that you're talking about so I'm
glad you're working your way through
them I here's what's funny about those
cards I got a note from the guy here his
name's Brian he's amazing he's the guy
that runs the products here at Ramsey
Solutions
he said that the printer notified him
that they're out of paper
that they can't keep these things in
stock and one of the cardinal sins of
this building is you'd never run out you
don't run out because people need help
and they finally click I want to buy
this thing and I'm going to start on my
journey to reading a new book to like
get healthier I want I want to talk to
my kids or my grandkids or I have an
eight-year-old grandson that lives with
me and he's nuts and I want to connect
with him and you finally click and it
says sold out so that's one of the
Cardinal rules and he reached out and
said hey
we ordered a new round and they sold out
within 48 hours and now that we've just
been notified there's no more paper like
we're out of paper so man
they're coming they'll be back but
um hey here's what's really exciting
that people are actually using those
cards and their bodies are remembering
here's what it feels like to actually be
engaged with somebody and then I love
your eight-year-old so creative he's
making his own cards that's fantastic
there's nothing magic about these
particular cards make your own that's
fan that's that is awesome and it's also
great that he's got a grandmother who's
willing to sit down and look him in the
eye and get done on his level and play
with him um that's that's a great great
gift to a dysregulated kid man
um so how can I help
well I have six children and
um yeah somebody said it would be fun to
have a big family okay
um
six adult children and four are mine and
two I inherited from my husband
um I was married for 22 years my husband
and I were in full-time Ministry
um he went kind of South there was a lot
of infidelity and we ended up divorcing
13 years ago
it devastated our children
um absolutely devastated them in every
way
um they walked away from their faith it
was devastating to our kids
um I met my husband my wonderful Papa
who also does the cards with us with the
eight-year-old grandson
um we met and married
um and he's been great the kids have
accepted him
um we have tried
very hard to make our home The Hub I
mean we have a playroom a nursery a pool
we have a sign up that says feed them
and they will come that was my husband's
idea because he's a deer hunter I didn't
really get what he was talking about
when he said honey I just think we need
to put food out and feed them like I do
the deer and I thought okay I don't know
where you're going with this but okay
so we did that we we we did that um and
for years now
um we've been married for 12 years and
it's just brought our family together
it was beautiful it was crazy good it
was so uh there was so much restoration
awesome
and then
our oldest son was involved in the
incident at work and I won't go into
what happened but he kind of lost his
mind and went from the perfect husband
to um did he cheat on his wife yeah he
did he did but it it was uh apples and
trees
yeah I guess so this is not the sign
that I would have thought would have
done that but that wasn't the husband
you thought would have done that either
right not at all not at all yeah
um so my husband and I were out of town
when this all came you know to the
surface and he uh asked if he could you
know stay with us for a while well we
have the Hub we have the big house and
I'm like of course you know he's very
close to that eight-year-old who I do
the cards with and I was like yeah sure
you know whatever we can do
well long story short his wife are
trying to work things out now which is
great however his wife thinks that we
took his side in this whole thing which
we didn't
um and she is now withholding their
four-year-old daughter from not just us
but the entire family
so I haven't seen this child and uh our
heart is broken yeah
um so that was one son what is it what
does that one son have to say about it
because it's his daughter too
you know he
we wish that he would be he's he's
walking on eggshells
um I get that
um he's he's not reconciling his wife
he's he is uh groveling
in that that isn't the
that's not the basis of a new
relationship everything about their
relationship is over the way it was it's
over
he cheated on his wife
and with a co-worker and so everything's
over and them choosing to stay together
awesome great I'm all about it
but they they're building something
completely new
and if he builds and is involved in
building something completely new and
sits in the corner and sucks his thumb
then what's get what's new is going to
be a world of her own creation it's
going to be created in a vacuum
and it's not going to be conducive to a
long-term relationship
see what I'm saying I absolutely do and
here's the big
ugly sad part of all of this
you can't do anything about it
uh
that's heartbreaking it's heartbreaking
you gotta grieve it it is sad I mean you
the one thing you could do is I don't
say confront is a dramatic word I don't
think confrontation but having a direct
conversation with your son
um about
what stories he's allowing his wife to
believe about his mom and dad
about him not taking owner's full
ownership of what happened about
um hey we're not going to start our new
life together that we're creating by
cutting out all of our old family like
whatever and I also don't blame her
quite honestly absolutely she watched
what hurts what his with his biological
dad did she's man she's like I want
nothing to do with his family I'm out
absolutely right and that it's just I
think there's this this
I gotta sit in it I've run up against
something and and I say this half ingest
half not ingest
there's something that a strong
um powerful Texas woman has run up
against it you just simply can't control
and it's it's not in it's not even in
your it's not in the cultural psychology
like you paid your house off man you got
out of debt you got remarried I mean
you've done hard things and you can't do
anything about this one
right
yeah you're right and
it's heartbreaking because it's this is
infiltrated you know other relationships
in the family
well no one gets to see
their little girl nobody
and that's grief
but the more you let that be something
that everybody talks about and
it's like there's a there's like a
poisoned glass on the counter and
everybody knows it's there
but then every time you all get together
somebody picks up that glass and pours a
little bit of it in everyone else's
drink just to make sure everybody feels
miserable
and that's just it it hurts but it
doesn't help anything
and so I can see a family prayer when
you all get together and say hey we
really miss young Susie whatever her
name is we miss her we really wish she's
here we miss her mom we miss her our our
your son
um and we hope that they're doing well
and then any choice to just dwell on it
as a group and can you believe this and
she's not any any choice down that road
it's just a choice to be miserable
and personally I don't need to dwell on
it like I have been I think I think at
some point you got to write her a letter
and tell you love her
and tell her
um though she doesn't see it or feel it
or believe it she'll always be your
daughter
and if she ever needs anything you're
here
I've done that in text messages text
messages the absolute worst way to
communicate with another human being God
got it it's a handwritten letter and
going back to the hand it gives her
something to hold on to and go back to
and this is not a woe is me this is not
a look what you've done this is you
simply saying I need you to hear from me
and see my handwriting I love you
you're my daughter you're a part of this
family
if you choose to leave my son I
understand I've been there
and I'll always love you and always care
care for you and I've always got your
back even when it feels like I don't
and that's it
that's it
okay I can do that
um you see do you see there's a moment
where y'all can Bond
you've been her
yeah I
I sure have
um
have you talked to her in that way
no because I've always tried to
try my hardest not to talk negatively
about their dad
um there's a difference between talking
like he's a crummy piece of crap
and hey honey
I've had my guts ripped out too
I've know that feeling of sitting on the
edge of the bed and not realizing what
day it is because everything in my world
is upside down
um
there's nothing to do with him I mean he
cheated that has to do with her and you
see how there's a there's such a
dramatic difference
I I do and you can tell her if you need
to say ugly things about him I'm I'm
fine to hear it
because I said my fair share about his
dad
well and frankly you know I'm having a
hard time you know wondering what the
heck happened to my son
and I'm having a hard time
respecting him I don't respect him I'm
forgiving him fair what were you
thinking have you have you asked him
no I haven't okay those secrets are
killing you
yeah and these aren't grenades these
aren't you coming after him being I
can't this is you taking your son out to
breakfast and saying hey
like it's been a season
we went through this with your dad
what happened
because my guess is he didn't like who
he had become he had a young kid he
probably outgoing like his old man or
whatever who knows man he didn't like
who he had become in his new age
and somebody else made him feel alive
for a few minutes and he blew the whole
thing up
yeah that's exactly what happened
he had an incident at work and that just
I don't know he fell off the wagon
it's it's it was horrible yeah okay sign
number two
I go through this one go through this
one quick so we're gonna run out of time
here okay
we set up joint accounts for our kids
because I got I started getting anxiety
over giving gifts
we're out of debt we started joint
account so we could give them money
uh for Christmas and birthdays awful
terrible terrible awful awful terrible
idea
please tell me why awful terrible idea
um because now we can't see that
granddaughter because my son started
dipping into my granddaughter's account
and my husband shut the account down as
he should have
and so now you have a son doing a temper
tantrum
and his
they are they're acting like little
children
yeah he's she's accusing my husband
of stealing from her daughter
here's the deal if he gave her money
he's given her money
right and for him to be like no I'm
taking it back that's kind of that's him
being a child
but when you give here's the deal your
kids are grown-ups you do not share
accounts with grown-up kids
especially not these days when you can
venmo money back and forth to somebody
or I can write you a check and put it in
the mail
I'm still old school like that I got a
checkbook in my bag right now like it's
1981. right so like I'm I'm not sharing
accounts number one number two if I want
to give money to my granddaughter for
like college or something I'm gonna open
an account that is an education account
like a 529 I'm going to open an account
and put it there or worse comes to worst
I'm going to open a money market account
like a low interest whatever and I'm
just going to open it myself and keep it
in there I've Got Friends two friends
who when my son and daughter were born
they opened a savings account for them
they did not give that savings account
to me every year on the birthday I get a
text message or a card or something that
says hey we deposited um we put some
money in your kids fund
and my guess is there'll be a couple of
thousand dollars when my kids graduate
college and it will just be a check that
comes in the mail or when they graduate
high school it'll be a check that comes
in the mail it's awesome but I'm not
holding it
and you know why they didn't give it to
me as a gift
like them not giving it to me was a gift
for our relationship
because they never have to wonder like
why is he spinning at that or what's
that for but they took all those
variables out they said hey we've got
some gifts for your kid that we're
putting into an account and we're
hanging on to it until the time is right
and it's their money that's fantastic
so do we write this daughter-in-law and
sign a letter as well how do we we
haven't seen this this one in four
months yeah here's the deal you're not
gonna try to say the right thing so you
can see the granddaughter
that's like saying I need to lose 50
pounds and going on like I'm gonna start
taking math and I'm gonna have like the
lower part of one of my legs removed so
I can lose 50 pounds you could get that
number on the scale but it's going to
come at such an ex like such a wild cost
that it's not going to be worth it
what you want to do is heal your
relationship with your son
your daughter-in-law heal your
relationship with your daughter-in-law
right
and so this is I this one sounds more
like a conversation
um that you have in person if they'll
have it if they won't then yeah you
write letters if they have it in person
and a hundred percent of this
conversation is you and your husband
saying we screwed up
okay we put we had joint accounts like
y'all were 14 years old you're not y'all
are adults
we thought the best way to to we didn't
think about setting up 529 accounts for
the kids we just were thinking about
cash and we put this burden on you guys
as to how we wanted you to and then we
took the money back we screwed it up so
we're starting from scratch
the money that we have for granddaughter
it's in a 529 now and we're going to
continue to fund that thing so the
moment she graduates high school we're
going to have this much money hopefully
for her to go to college
and if you're still having to give your
son cash so that he can live that's a
whole other conversation and problem
yeah
and if you want to buy gifts for your
kids or for your grandkids buy them a
gift and send it to them or buy them a
gift card and mail it to them
okay
yes it makes sense
just don't you're over complicating it
you're overthinking it
and there's something to be said for
starting from scratch and saying I miss
my little boy
there's something to be said by calling
his wife and saying I miss my
daughter-in-law
it's miss you
and I've screwed this whole thing up and
I'm sorry can we meet can we talk
and we're not doing this just Wing see
grandkid again we're doing this because
we want to heal these relationships
and the reason I by the way for those
listening the reason I would say one
write a letter one is is
Woman to Woman
hurt woman to hurt woman
I'm identifying in your pain
and when you're entering into somebody
else's pain
there's all kinds of walls and defense
mechanisms built into somebody else's
protecting themselves from getting hurt
again
and so a letter is a great way to give
somebody else the opportunity to read
and on their time their schedule when
they can deal with it
they can read this letter
and they can read it again and they can
read it again
the other one is hey man I blew it with
the money we're not we're not healing
relationships as much as y'all are
throwing a temper tantrum we screwed
this up let's just we're just gonna
start this thing over and again just
like I said with the first um with your
with your first son
if they say you can never see this
granddaughter again ever ever
they can do that because it's their kid
and it will be heartbreaking it'll be
something that you and your husband have
to grieve deeply
together but it will be the way it is
and you can still send gifts you can
still write letters to that
granddaughter you can still send cards
but you're gonna have to grieve the loss
I'm sorry
my gut tells me that some
you being vulnerable you going first you
saying I'm sorry and here's how we're
going to make this right
um we'll go a long long way to showing
your kids and their spouses
mom and dad are safe now our mom and
stepdad are safe now we can go back home
the goal is always letting your kids
know they have a place at home here